hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about histones and DNA packaging and
specifically how those things histones
and DNA packaging answer this question
how does DNA fit inside the nucleus so
if we think about DNA and for this
example let's talk about human DNA the
human genome has approximately 3 billion
nucleotides so that's a pretty long
complex molecule if the human genome was
stretched out in ten it would be about
1.8 meters or about five feet long so
this is a very very large amount of
material so again how does it fit inside
the nucleus and not only how does it fit
but how does it fit in a in an organized
way so that specific genes can be found
when the cell needs access to them and
well the answer is a highly regulated
process of DNA packaging so let's talk
about how that process works we know
that DNA at its most basic level is a
double helix and the double helix will
wrap around proteins called histones
and histones are important for more than
just being a medium for the DNA to wrap
around they're actually highly important
for regulation that is these proteins
called histones have parts that are
called tails that stick out even after
the DNA has wrapped around and depending
on how those tails are modified what
kinds of groups are added onto those
tails that can effectively silence a
gene keeping it from being transcribed
or it can make that gene available for
transcription thereby turning the gene
on so the histones themselves play
essential regulatory roles now when the
DNA when the double helix wraps around
the histone proteins it looks kind of
like this now this each one of these
orange dots is a group of histone
proteins that has a few loops of the
double helix wrapped around them so this
is actually quite a lot of DNA and we're
looking at it not as close up as we are
in this view here now you can see from
this appearance that when the double
helix wraps around the histone proteins
it is it gives an appearance of beads on
a string and that's how this is often
referred to
so here the beads would be groups of
histone proteins with the double helix
wrapped around them and the string would
be areas of double helix between the
various groupings of histones and
overall these each one of these little
beads is called a nucleosome so here we
have many many nucleosomes now the tails
of the histone proteins in addition to
being used for regulation one of the
ways in which they are regulatory is
that the tails actually interact with
each other and so depending on how those
tails have been modified whether the
genes in this area need to be on or off
in regards to transcription those tails
can interact and actually cause all of
these nucleosomes to wrap up together to
form essentially loops that are known as
thick chromatin fibers then thick
chromatin fibres are further compacted
into a type of packaging known as looped
domains and this further compaction
happens when the cell is about to
undergo mitosis
and then there's even further packaging
and compaction of the DNA from loops
domains into what we know of as the
compact metaphase chromosome so this is
what we see on the metaphase plate
in the middle of mitosis and so you can
see how much goes in to packaging a huge
amount of nucleotides a huge long
molecule of the DNA double helix going
through all of these different steps to
get to a compact chromosome and what is
especially interesting is that this
process as it goes on again and again in
multiple cells you have specific genes
that are always in the same place in
this packed chromosome and the fact that
this process can be done again and again
and again and the genes always end up in
the same physical locations on the
compact chromosome indicates that this
overall process is highly precise
and as a result of being highly precise
that means that it is also highly
repeatable so that each time a cell is
gearing up for mitosis and it's going to
go through this process you're always
going to get genes being in the same
place on the same chromosome and genes
being in the same place relative to each
other in this nucleus tomé formation
when the cells are not going through
mitosis actively so that is it for
today's video on histones and DNA
packaging
thank you for watching biology professor
I hope you learned a lot